welcome to the behind-the-scenes for our
Assassin's Creed 4 video called what
called the devil's sphere yeah which is
actually a interesting name because it's
named after Blackbeard's insignia which
he flew above his ship a little pirate
history back there because the skeleton
stabbing a heart yeah with the spear
yeah so we decided to call that because
Blackbeard's kind of a main character in
this video kind of like using the game
is like the best BTS ever so far let's
keep this rolling
I shared a great time filming this video
it was a lot of hard work wasn't it Nico
it was a lot of hard work this all in
three days it's pretty nuts yeah we shot
pretty much this entire thing in only
three days however we had about I'd say
month month and a half to plan it out
and uh it took a lot of work took out we
had to wrangle huge boats unlike any
other production we had huge boats ah we
had like a pirate bar we had all these
things it's the biggest video we've ever
shot for sure it's crazy crazy you think
about it when you say it like that yeah
Australia as I went out one morning fare
away all the way there I met Miss Nancy
Blair where boundary yeah Oh your roving
King to me hey bow way all the way all
the way you'll hear me say we're bound
for South Australia yeah day one star of
India
I'm playing Rob August or I'm not
playing first day of shooting on the
Star of India I'm Rob August I'm playing
Edward Kenway from Assassin's Creed 4
Black Flag and we're about to do the
first scene scene one take one mark all
right we need to go are you ready
hi I'm Alan Heyburn and I'm playing the
consulate and I have to wear some [ __ ]
in high heels so I'm expecting some
sprained ankles yeah authentic it's
right
hi I'm Andy I'm the costumer and
wardrobe person on this project it's a
really huge project I think this is the
most people I've ever tried to dress on
set we have like a bunch of extras that
are pirates and sailors and stuff and
they were provided by Richard rassner
who's the captain of Clan dark sail a
pirate reenactment group his people
brought a bunch of their costumes and
we've sort of been you know styling and
trying to stuff on different people
seeing what works I put together the
consulate and the privateer and
Blackbeard and our awesome Edward Kenway
costumes were rented from a very
talented costumer I wish we knew who
made them but they're gorgeous they're
identical costumes we got one for the
stunt guy and one hero costume you sir
come here would you owe more than even
the directors is it appropriate am i
looking ahead she's doing a well
flashing it out so it's about the dirt
it's about a grit take a look at this
hands this man's hands this man's hands
that's like Blackbeard it's not possible
to make because I'm a dainty man where
care that's that man what kind of a
sailor has dainty hands you know terra
firma you know what you know you're a
pirate captain would have cleaned me I'm
saying that's why I'm asking you
it's dirty living aboard a ship all the
ropes are covered in tar and plus just
touching any of the others like argh
nice to see our [ __ ] at dock
action took the ship without firing a
single shot I'm cutting fantastic
beautiful got it that's been seen it's a
hard one
so those are the longest most worried
lines well I'm just gonna get one last
shot here it's giving you two coming in
busting in oh my god looking around for
the captain pretending like you're
talking to each other a little bit
you'll talk talk talk you pretend like
you're having your conversation but a
Bridget and then I'll kind of say go and
then you guys will go like all right we
have to go eat lunch and then you like
walk out here and go eat lunch also for
this shoot red is actually coming out
doing a little behind-the-scenes
featurette on us as well kind of talking
about how we use red cameras in our
production that kind of stuff if we can
link to it on YouTube if it goes up on
YouTube this is probably the part where
you can click on an annotation if not
eCos gonna feel really silly for those
hand motions might be on Vimeo - we'll
see yeah whatever all right so we're
setting up a wire gag for Assassin's
Creed where Edward are assassins gonna
jump up from the top deck now it's
really is a really high drop so what
we're doing is we're setting with a
two-pilot system and to make sure
there's no friction on any part of the
rope to make sure it comes out smooth
and fast this is a little different for
what we've rigged before but we've only
down it down the speed is good it's not
swinging back and forth getting anything
get up set
nobody vote this ship is ours
one Casson all right
ever let's go read my copy of this
pathetic cut nice let's do one more even
faster like let's go meet the captain of
this pathetic grow you know really fast
just let it fly let's meet the captain
of this pathetic broom
great yep great moving on
Oh
I spent some time on boats and I don't
think there's anything that really makes
me more happy come with me then being
able to look out and see pretty much the
distance and the horizon nothing else
you know it's actually really beautiful
wait it's four o'clock yeah we're
rolling back like six I got two hours to
bust the stunt height thing I can give
you some art I'm directing a movie is
like conducting an orchestra for ten
hours straight
it's intense so Ken we're gonna break
this first section at two pieces so it's
easier to do
Luke the Sun according to suggested I
start rolling on the guys they were
practicing sticks I'm to nail it and so
I've actually been filming the fight
scene where they've been practicing and
getting the shots so and then I just put
this plastic thing over and just the
thing is since it's kind of weird and
janky just you know don't fling it off
because you could very quickly do that
sorry guys take a good chunk of time
before you start fighting look change a
circle if he starts to advance he doing
a fight yet take a step back okay
just really take your time
hi there i'm chris messina chopper this
is my camera operator Erin and today we
worked on the Assassin's Creed video
with corridor digital and it's been
freaking awesome si fly and octocopter
that means it's got eight arms and eight
motors on it I have what's called a
heavy lifter we can actually lift a red
scarlet so we've been lifting a red
scarlet today and flying it over the
ocean and it's been really scary but
likely we're able to we're able to make
it happen okay
it's on the camera operator so I'll do
pans and tilts I'll track subjects and
yeah we can run the red scarlet from it
we can film from it check exposure
everything all from the goggles and then
we even have a monitor that's Sam or
Nick or whoever can Mont watch what
we're seeing as well so it's really cool
setup hey Internet this guy he goes by
the name ssj Aaron I go by the name
Sidewinder not going inside water that's
because we both started filmmaking
a VFX forum about 13 years ago 14 years
ago and he just happened to be on the
shoot as the hexacopter octocopter
camera guy yeah so making connections
internet friends yet friends real-life
friends say
words to mingle
quartermaster star quarter-way non-irish
bouzouki and tin whistle
hi I'm gonna master castle on the objet
I'm focused I'm boughs in Deckard core
Dwayne mandolin I'm first mate Riven
roll and I do toy panic
I'm Ruby Juba and I put a get tired
navigator smithy crow I play bass
I'm captain wolfurio Freddy I play
accordion and together we represent the
United People's Association otherwise
known as the dread crew of odd would
talk rom-com said if you're more
interested about what we do you can
check us out at www.opm.gov/openseason
his lap some awkward family service is
really offered a hi I'm Amanda Lynn I'm
playing the bar wench tonight and I'm
having an awesome time so far just
drinking beer and snuggling up on
sailors so it's pretty fun shoot I'll be
honest I'm a guy who rolls out caffeine
so I do it having squibs at 3 a.m. also
helps keep you up
ow
so it's 703 a.m. and we have been here
since about 6:00 p.m. yesterday and
honestly though for an all-nighter shoot
this has been one of the smoothest ones
we've had definitely a little pinch of
stress right in the middle
but after changing our approach to the
shoot we successfully shot out pretty
much everything we needed you can only
get big places and you make full boob
thanks guys and bye bull Moo's I mean
reckless yeah there's a lot of bold
moves made with this video this is the
boldest move of all so we're on this
boat we're out at sea
obviously we're stuck on that boat we're
not gonna go swimmin or anything we're
stuck for their whole day and so we
somehow someone clogs one of the toilets
one of the toilets or of them anyway so
this pretty much results in everyone
pissing off the side of the ship and not
just any part astray we're talking about
the edge of the ship you feet are like
this and there's like like 15 feet of
nothing between you and just like ocean
waves and you're there you're like this
like you're like this sails flap you
feel free every once in your life
at one point some girls drove by out of
yacht and this girl showed us her butt
and then we were like god damn it and I
like wait I was like yeah I hear ya
boats in the back we have butts in the
back yeah but boats yeah just think of
the comments they're like oh for 32 but
boat